foreign minister thank you very much for
talking to Sky News let me ask you first
of all to characterize this moment for
Moldova Moldova has been in a very
difficult region for you know at a very
difficult time uh we're Ukraine's most
fragile neighbor of course we've been
affected in multiple ways and now of
course we see that the situation is
getting worse it's getting worse in
Ukraine because the war drags on and is
is affecting more and more people and as
you could see in the last few days with
some explosions taking place in the
transnistrian region of Moldova we are
also increasingly affected by by this
Regional
destabilization let's talk about those
explosions first of all
um who was responsible for them well we
don't know it's not a part of Legally
the transistorian region as part of
Moldova de facto of authorities don't
have control so we don't control we
don't have access to CCTV cameras to
forensics we have some working
hypotheses but we're not in a situation
to attribute clear responsibility for
these attacks what Madam president
sandus said publicly is that our
understanding is that whereas the
absolute majority of residents of
transnistri want to live in a peaceful
environment and they don't want to end
up in a war zone there are nonetheless
forces inside transnistria which
hope to benefit from rising tensions and
they have staged this provocation which
was the attack on interruple to what
extent does the future of your country
as an independent nation depend on
Ukraine's success at pushing back Russia
well I think the future of the entire
continent uh
rests on the capacity of Ukraine to
maintain
its political system its country its
resilience and in this sense
with faith and the future of every
country in this part of the world of
entire Europe
depends on on how this war ends and
where it ends and when it ends
are you asking the West uh Western
Nations for help militarily are you
asking for weapons uh we have we're a
neutral country by our constitution this
constitution was adopted in 1994 but
neutrality does not exclude and prevent
us from cooperating on security on
foreign policy on defense matters we're
not at the stage of talking about uh
weapon supplies but of course we have
for a long time we've had very good
Cooperative links between our ministry
of defense and our partners between our
police and our partners and those
conversations still continue and there's
projects where our military cooperates
with NATO member states Russia has has
now openly said it was a Russian general
a week or two ago openly talked about an
exit
through to transnistria they are trying
to to join the dots east to west through
southern Ukraine and potentially link up
the Breakaway state of transnistia that
that surely must make you here in
Kissena feel very vulnerable statements
such as the one made by this Russian
general are
are really worrying it's of course
completely unhelpful of course but
creates new tensions
formerly the Russian Federation
dissociated themselves from the
statement so formerly Russia says that
that position has not been an agreed
message at the same time we all know
that the situation is quite volatile
volatile it's risky we constantly see
voices inside Russia calling on on a
kind of bigger and more ambitious War
aims at the same time it's also clear
that the war in Ukraine has not been
going according to plan so here
intentions can be intentions but the
realities on the ground always tend to
safer I think it's fair to say that that
much of the world misjudged Vladimir
Putin and his intentions
from where you're sitting here in this
crucial geographical location what do
you think
he is trying to do and what he might do
next
I mean we're not in a position to
speculate or predict but it's our
responsibility to be preparing for the
full spectrum of scenarios and
contingencies and that's what the
government normally does so if you ask
me what are we preparing for I'll ask
you I'll tell you what we're preparing
for positive scenarios but also for very
negative ones and everything in between
and that's Our obligation irrespective
of what other countries our leaders plan
to do or maybe they don't plan now but
they will plan in a couple of years the
responsibility of a government of a
security sector of a defense of defenses
of the institutions responsible for the
difference of the country is always to
be planning for the full spectrum of
threats and to that end you don't rule
out asking for Weaponry to defend
yourselves if it came to that listen
we're not in a position of now
prejudging of how things will evolve
I'll tell you very frankly that it's
also dangerous to prejudge and speculate
but it we are nonetheless preparing and
we have been preparing for all possible
contingencies
and what exactly we do within this
preparation we prefer not to discuss in
details when it comes to things to to
the Future which we of course cannot
predict